あっち、そっち、はじめです！
UUUMと講談社が手組んでやっているボンボンTVっていうチャンネルがあるんですけども
そのチャンネルにいる【よっち】っていう男がいまして、
最近ちょっと調子のってるなと思ってね（怒り💢）、
いやボンボンTVもね最近調子がいいみたいでねこうねいい感じに上がっているすよボンボンTV
あっ良かったら、チャンネル登録よろしくお願いします。
て俺がかこうなんかやっちゃてるからさ
こう、ボンボンTVも波に乗ってこういい感じになって
よっちがますます調子に乗ると
だめだなぁ、よっち、初心を忘れるべからずだぞ、よっち！
なぁ、よっち、なぁ、なぁ、よっち（笑）
というわけで、ちょっとね、よっちをね、やっぱ
よっちは昔はねこう初初しくて、
こうなんか健全な感じだったんですけど
最近はもなんかね、亭主関白みたいになってしまって
あのやさしいよっちはどこへいってしまったんだ（涙）
俺は、非常に悲しい（涙）
というわけで、僕は、そんなよっちを、ボッコボコにしようと思います！！
で、今からよっちが僕ん家に来るんですけども
ちょっと、よっちに、ドッキリをしてあげようと思います
まぁ、そんなちょっと生温いドッキリだと
やっぱ、彼は、このままだと、た、とんでもないことになっちゃうんで
そうならないためにも、ちょっとね、やっぱ
この僕が、責任をもってなんとかしてあげようと思っています。
今回のドッキリは
まぁ、要するに、僕が借金取りにすっげー襲われるっていうっていうドッキリです
よっちがが家に来てしばらくした後に後輩が、
時間差で借金取りの真似をして僕ん家に来るんで
ビンタしろとか、胸倉つかめとか結構言ってあるんで
かなりね、盛り上がると思います
僕が借金取りに襲われてる中でよっちはどう行動するか
いやー、ちょっと最近調子乗ってるから
その、焦ってる顔とかみたいっすよ
よっちの
というわけで、よっち覚悟しとけ
ではいこう！！
よっち）　はい、皆さんこんにちは。SEIKIN TVのセイキンです　（セイキンの物まね）
はじめ）　はい、皆さんこんにちは。SEIKIN TVのセイキンです　（セイキンの物まね）
は）　ちょっと前向きになっちゃう
よ）そうそうそうｗｗｗｗ
（チャイムと扉を強くたたく音）
（ドン）
は）うわー、なになになに？？
は）なになになに
（チャイム）
（扉を強くたたく音）
は）はい、今出ます。今出ます。
借金取り役の後輩たち）　おい💢
はじめしゃちょー）　　　はい
後輩）お前いつ返すんだ
は）　すみません。
後輩）おい、　は）申し訳…
後輩）なぁ、　は）よっち！
後輩）なぁ、　は）すみません。はい
後輩）何やってんの、お前
後輩）ホントによ　　は）すみません
後輩）は？　　は）すみません
後輩）話ちげぇんじゃねーの？
は）申し訳ないっす。
後輩）は？
後輩）　（舌打ち）誰だこいつ、おい
は）いや、関係ないっす
後輩）は？
は）彼は
後輩）は？　おい、お前な、お前何やってんだよ
よ）あっ、いやいやいや
は）彼は関係ないです。
後輩）は？ねぇ、おい
後輩）お前金貸してるよな
後輩）いくら貸してるんだ。俺らに、おい
後輩）おいおいおいおい
後輩）な、なに、このくそメガネ、おい
よ）すみません
後輩）こいつに話あんだよ。お前あっち行ってろ
は）よっち、いいよ
後輩）おい。あっち行ってろ。おい
よ）話しなくちゃいけない
後輩）いやいや、話こいつにしてんだよ　あ💢
後輩）なぁ、ホントに、なぁ💢
は）よっち、いいよ、ホントに大丈夫
後輩）なぁ、なんだんだよ、おい💢
後輩）おい💢
は）すみません
後輩）おい、なんだよ、おい
よ）あ…。ちょっと
は）、いいよ、上行ってて
後輩）おい💢
後輩）おい、返せって言ってんだろ
後輩）いつかえす？何円？忙しいのか？
は）ら、来月には
後輩）あ💢　あ💢　は？
は）来月、来月中には、
後輩）来月？は？
は）よっちとりあえず上行ってて、上行ってて
後輩）は？笑ってんな
は）　すみません
よ）あー、いやいや
後輩）は？
は）よっちとりあえずいいよ
よ）あーちょっと、あーちょっと
は）よっち大丈夫大丈夫、これは俺の責任だから大丈夫大丈夫
後輩）おい、
は）すみません
後輩）おい、なんなんだよこいつ、おい
後輩）あ💢何笑っとんじゃ
は）申し訳ないっす
後輩）あ💢ざけんじゃねぇぞ
よ）あーいやーちょっと
は）申し訳ないっす
は）とりあえず、あのーホント、申し訳ないっす
後輩）じゃー、明日お前、おい、明日
は）はい。
後輩）朝、朝、じゃー、6時には引き取りにくるからな
後輩）お前用意しておけよ、ホントに、おい
は）すみません　はい
後輩）ちゃんと見ろこっちを、次ねぇーからな
は）はい
よ）明日、はい
後輩）おい、わかっんてな
は）すみません
（勢いよくドアが閉まる音）
は）っていう、ドッキリです笑
は）お疲れさまー
は）えっ、まって、まって、まって、よっち、ホントに、え、まって、ホントに気づいてなかった？
よ）マジで来たと思って
は）え？ホントに信じてた？え？まじで？
よ）いや、ホントに危ないと思って
は）ドッキリ大成功！！！
はじめしゃちょー　後輩）うぇーい！！！！